à court terme il faut résoudre le
problème de la gouvernance de cette
university là où le bât blesse entre le
pôle martinique et la guadeloupe est une
question de répartition des moyens
donc nous demandons effectivement qu'il
y ait quand même une expertise de cette
histoire de moyens et donc à moyen terme
nous demandons justement qu'il y ait
très rapidement et les révisions de la
loi ou une abrogation de la loi parce
que nous avons un fonctionnement
guy l'université qui prête à confusion
avec des pouvoirs à un président et les
mêmes pouvoirs à deux vice-présidents de
paul donc nous demandons que ce que que
les choses soient clarifiées par une
révision des statuts une abrogation de
la loi sinon une nouvelle rédaction de
la loi
voilà ce que nous avons demandé pour
l'instant